hi everybody it is so nice to be here
and to chat with you about building a
vlog with r
a little bit about me
um i have the great pleasure of working
at our studio with rachel and many
others and i am the senior product
marketing manager
and currently i focus on the strategy
and the content creation for the r
studio blog
it's been an amazing almost five months
and again it's just been amazing to have
the opportunity to work with others at
our studio and others in the data
science community
and as such i would love to hear your
compelling data science stories and if
you are ever interested in collaborating
on posts on the r studio blog please
consider this an open invitation to
reach out to me
we can brainstorm we can collaborate if
you're already thinking about something
in particular so again really excited to
um
to communicate with you and then also
chat with you about how to create your
own blog
and so just a little bit more about me
and my free time i'm also very active in
the art community i'm a proud our lady
seattle co-organizer and sometimes i
post on my personal blog as well
and so my very first our ladies talk was
actually on the vlog down uh package way
back in 2018 funnily enough so i'm
really excited so many years later to
continue talking about building a blog
with r
and so just a quick intro question if
you have any data science or technical
blogs that you love to read please put
them in the chat and feel free to share
why you love them so much
so
today's agenda that we'll be going
through
are possible reasons for creating a blog
uh the sort of topics and um that you
might like want to consider and other
things that you want to
take note of before building your blog
and then of course the actual tools for
building your blog with r
and i have a lot of resources in this
repository
so that they are easy to find as well as
the slides that you see here so if you
have any questions like rachel mentioned
please put them in slido or in the chat
and we can discuss them at the end of
today's
presentation
so while today's talk uh title is
building a blog with r we're actually
going to be talking about websites a
little bit more generally so a blog is a
very specific type of website that has a
reverse chronological order where the
newer content appears first and it can
allow for things like comments and can
be syndicated on rss feeds
index etc
and some website pages can be quite
static
and they're not updated very frequently
whereas a blog tends to be very dynamic
you want to keep it
fresh with content
and there are also other sorts of
websites that support dialogue and can
serve as sort of libraries of knowledge
such as wikis or forums but blogs
specifically add this kind of time
factor to consider them successful
because you want continuous engagement
continuous content
and the type of content considered for a
vlog
is different too it could be more real
time to things like events that are
happening and more of an opinion rather
than a reference and we'll get into that
as well later
and so
uh just to reiterate uh while we're
talking about blogs specifically know
that r can actually be used to create
these other types of websites as well
and so we should talk about why create a
blog in the first place
and i would like to glean
apologies if uh kind of
um
sorry
okay so i'd like to glean some insights
that i've seen from other people's talks
uh david robinson once wrote if you've
given advice three times then it's time
to consider giving a blog
on the resources page that i shared with
you i actually created a youtube
playlist in case you want to see a talks
from allison hill vicky boykiss miles
salmon this one from david robinson if
you'd like to hear their insights as
well
but
in terms of like sharing a blog
there are various different heck things
that come to mind
so
uh being able to
share your opinions and uh what you've
learned if there's a package that you
investigated for a particular project or
um something that is sort of workflow or
process that you went through and you
want others to learn about
like i mentioned earlier blogs are also
an opportunity to write about your own
opinions and kind of share the insight
that you've gained from your expertise
and your experience and uh if you care
to do so you can also get feedback and
um the form of comments or uh social
media discussion and things like that
and then also to give updates and news
and let other folks know
what is going on in the world
but thinking about a data science
community
specifically
blogs can really help showcase the kind
of soft skills needed for data
scientists
it can uh provide a platform to share
sorry i already said that
it allows you to practice writing for
someone other than yourself
it can form a sort of portfolio of work
and makes it very easy to share because
everything is in one place and and it
kind of centralizes your work rather
than having things in various different
spots
and so uh when you watch those talks and
more generally we often talk about
reasons behind creating a personal blog
especially if you're looking for a job
but i also want to note that your team
or organization could also benefit from
having a blog so external blogs like the
ones that we have at our studio for
example these
quick aside just so you're aware we have
four different vlogs the our studio blog
which is the one that i helped manage
the ai blog which has the latest news of
ai technologies and whose website is
actually built with distilled that we're
going to be talking about later one of
the tools for creating uh blogs
and then the rvu's blog which it
presents stories from the our community
and uh is actually built with blog down
the other tool that we'll be talking
about later and then the tidy verse vlog
which uses hugo down which
focuses on just hugo whereas the other
package that i mentioned blog down
actually lets you use other kinds of
static web site generators and so i just
wanted to quickly share that our studio
actually uses our in many different ways
to build our blogs
and so our blogs help keep the community
up to date with events and products uh
just to show a few different examples
here is one showcasing the community
events like this one today and uh just
letting folks know in terms of
what is happening this month what
happened last month and where to find
different sorts of resources
another thing we like to do is showcase
what's possible with all the cool data
science
teams and tools that are out there and
so this is an example from the
netherlands that actually built a shiny
app and scaled it to hundreds of doctors
in order to track covet cases and make
decision making based on that data and
information
and then the other thing is providing
thought leadership and providing a like
i mentioned earlier opinions about a
particular topic and so
our studio does put these out as well so
for example our stance on
interoperability between python between
and r
and then also things like the unique
ways that code first data science can
help uh
companies and teams be able to
successfully create a
a data science team
and so in addition to an external site
you should also consider an internal
site for our blog for your team as well
as this is an our enterprise community
meetup this is actually the use case
we'll be mostly focusing on today
and internal blogs uh can help you
share information between team members
in an easier and more efficient way i
don't know if you've ever tried to find
some advice that your colleague sent you
over email uh it can be really hard to
find
and with a blog the key information can
be in one place it can be searchable
with tags and so this just speeds up
communication uh since everything is
organized within your blog
and uh serving as a sort of bulletin
board of ongoing projects and news
uh folks can search for information from
the past while easily seeing what is the
newest info
and so generally it gives your opportu
colleagues an opportunity to collaborate
and share their knowledge if they know
that there's a place that they can go to
when they have something they want to
share
and
with a consolidated place like a blog
folks thoughts can be shared very
quickly
to many people rather than siloed in
conversations or emails
and others can learn about what their
teammates are thinking about as well
and so ideally a internal blog can
foster a community that's open and
inclusive and share the message that you
all care about each other's work and
your opinions and your experience
and so there are a few differences
between an internal blog and an external
blog
you don't have to worry about things
like keywords or searchability
your audience is
confined to those in the organization so
you know exactly
how to find them and the topics can be a
little bit more flexible rather than
your company or your products like with
an official corporate vlog
and
uh there are many different types of
posts that you can consider for your
blog as well
and this very much depends on your goals
the sort of information that your team
finds useful
however let's say you want to create a
blog for an internal data science
community
so topics for your community can include
things like reflections on past projects
how things went a summary of events any
lessons learned
where to find the outputs for example
you could pose things like virtual
proposals to get feedback and review
and of course things like news and
updates are very well suited to blog
posts but as you can see here there's
many many different types that you can
consider in terms of uh how to actually
write the information that you want to
share
and then besides these there's also the
actual content um
and blog posts are a little bit about
finding a sweet spot in terms of life
and media like whether you want a fully
text article images photos infographics
videos podcasts etc there's so many
different ways of actually composing a
blog post
and you don't have to worry so much
about optimization like i mentioned
earlier but you still want to make sure
that
your your
content is engaging and useful
and like i mentioned earlier too blog
posts can serve as a forum for
discussion if you have comments
available on there
uh but one thing i do want to mention is
that a blog is not the place for
absolutely everything
and so this is a framework that i find
very helpful it's called the dye taxi
framework and it
tries to provide structure for technical
documentation
so a successful technical team needs a
mix of all of these tutorials how to's
explanations and references
and so it's always important to consider
if you have a blog
what is
the right place for a particular type of
documentation whether it should be
stored somewhere else in another
location
or if it makes sense to write a blog
post about it and then save it somewhere
else a little bit more permanently
or
write a blog post about something to
raise awareness of a particular resource
so it helps people or point people to it
for the future
but
that is the one caveat that i want to
mention not everything is suited for a
blog post
inside a organization
and so
in addition like what else you need to
consider if you want to write an
internal blog
i think first and foremost is why do you
want to create an internal blog and what
are your goals and your ultimate purpose
are you hoping to get viewership
for just your team or outside of your
team for others at the organization and
you hope that they are interested in the
work as well
are you hoping that the blog stays
focused about work projects um or is it
more of an opportunity to learn more
about the personal experiences of others
and so having a clear goal can help you
develop your blog
what it looks like and help you explain
to others its goals and purposes as well
and related to your goals uh i think
it's very important to illustrate the
values that you want to instill uh so if
your blog is meant to be a place for
inclusivity openness a way to motivate
your coworkers then you want to make
sure that the content of your blog
demonstrates your values and that your
colleagues are aware of these values as
well
and another thing to consider is again
what would be helpful and relevant
content
what do you want to share that your
readers will actually want to read
and for an internal data science
community uh what would be interesting
enough to check in periodically at your
blog to learn more
for your teammates uh key to success is
knowing what others find valuable and
making sure that your blog reflects that
information
and like we mentioned before we don't
want a blog to confuse uh others because
of the other forms of documentation that
already exist within an organization
so it's important to know
what's in and out of your blog
the tone style and voice that it will
have
and what sort of content are within the
guardrails of your blog and what is not
of course as time goes on and you learn
things things may change but having
these in place can help you
understand how you think you'll meet
your goals and adapt accordingly
and ideally you can get your colleagues
involved in content creation as well
this way you can showcase many different
voices and perspectives and keep your
blog updated with diverse ideas
uh of course and
this means your colleagues must be
excited to be involved and share their
own skill sets and this can be done
through direct invitations and but it is
helpful if you have firm values and
great content for your blog
to help encourage collaboration
and then another thing to note is that
you want to get buy-in for your blog
not just from your teammates but also
from your leadership team since it takes
time to create content you might have to
make the case uh that it's worth the
time and effort of not just you but also
your colleagues to keep a frequently
updated blog
and this is done through the creation of
valuable content
work that makes it interesting and
useful and applicable to others and
being able to communicate the value of
that work to higher-ups
and with inviting folks to collaborate
you want to make sure that your blog
reflects your values uh
apparently yes
um
and so if
like if your blog's values are to be
inclusive you don't want to
unintentionally
exclude folks with the topics or the way
that folks respond to discussions so
getting consistent feedback and health
uh can help determine whether your blog
is truly benefiting your team and
reflecting the values that you want to
put in place
and related to ownership you want the
blog to be a part of the routine of your
work
so that it doesn't feel like a big
imposition or burden on you or others
perhaps your coworkers have given a
confidence talk or you just had a big
strategy meeting can a blog post just be
part of the workflow so that the blog
has regular content but it's not a
creation of a whole new thing
and if it's already
somewhat integrated then it's a lot
easier to keep the blog going
and then finally there is the technical
stuff too
so there's the actual
tools that you'll be using to build your
blog and the training around those tools
you don't want something like a vlog to
disappear when a particular person you
know moves to another team or something
like that
and hopefully you can build the skills
across your team the infrastructure
across your organization and to keep it
going
and so
to build a blog with our specifically
you uh at least for the tools that i
will mention today you'll have to have
some skills like our and our markdown
and make sure that it's not uh
just one person but multiple people that
has those skills in place or at least a
workflow to help those who are still
learning are marked down
so that they are also able to contribute
to the blog if they want to
and while you don't need the system like
github it's it's incredibly helpful to
have
uh version control can help resolve the
issues like if a particular conflict is
two people edit the same file at the
same time or something like that
and it can help keep track of changes
and then when they happen being able to
revert it and things like that so highly
recommend having conversion control in
place
and then of course you need a place to
actually host your website
and uh there are a few different options
for
if you're looking for a personal website
which we'll go through today
if you're looking for a blog for your
internal um
company then you
will need to take other considerations
into place like if you want it behind
your server so that it's secure or
behind a password or on other protected
hosting services
that like netlifly or rcdo connect which
i guess we'll go through later
so today's demo uh we're going to be
talking about two different packages
blog down is an r package that creates
websites using our markdown and hugo
which is a static website generator and
this is by default it actually can work
on other with other site generators as
well like jekyll
and distill for our markdown is a web
publishing format optimized for
scientific and technical communication
it uses pandoc and the distilled
frameworks to create the websites and so
we'll be taking a look at these two
different packages and seeing what a
blog
looks like in both cases
and in terms of how do you decide
between log down or distill uh there are
a few factors
say you want to have a lot of
flexibility and configure your website a
lot then blog down would be the way to
go
distill is a bit more minimal you can
edit the theme and some colors but
as we'll see block down has a lot of
variety in terms of things and gives you
a lot of options um
but uh there is you know a flip side to
this with all that flexibility it means
that the still is a lot more stable than
blocked down uh things like if the hugo
version or the theme
changes and breaks
then you have to you know consider other
options for your website and so
very much depends on the direction that
you want your blog to go
so right now i'm going to stop sharing
for one second
and then move over to
a few other things okay
can you see my skin okay yep i can see
the hugo themes
excellent great
so these are
um the hugo things that i mentioned with
the many many different variety of
options that you have for your website
um and so my personal website is
actually on uh log down or used uh
created using blog down i created um
with my co-organizers website for our
lady seattle using this theme and so
this is available on the github
repository that i shared in case you
want to take a look at all the various
scenes that are available
on hubo
and so i did want to mention this one
particular theme it's called hugo
apparel
and it is uh like it says here a hugo
theme you'll want to hang out with uh
created by alison hill and our markdown
team is a really really great website uh
yes website to consider if you uh are
interested in creating a blog with log
down and so
as you can see it has this particular
format and then in addition to that it
has different layouts for the type of
content that you might want to consider
creating and so this is what the blog
setup looks like
with different
links uh showcased this way
if you click into it you can see
how
it allows you to use the different our
markdown features for example these
different tab sets
also gives you a layout like this called
projects where it's a little bit more
static like i mentioned earlier but
could be well suited for a particular
type of content that you want to share
and just generally
has like a lot of different uh
capabilities if you click into here
uh
in terms of what we talked about earlier
the consolidation of work this lets you
um take a talk link the website link the
code have it all in one spot
and so i created this a demo site if you
are interested in creating an internal
blog for for your team or your
organization or whatnot what it could
possibly look like using that hugo
apparel scene and so
uh using some great content from rachel
thank you rachel uh here are some
examples of what a
series of blog posts could look like and
so folks you know whether they're new to
the team or have been around for a while
can go in here and uh you know take in
the great uh advice from their
colleagues at any point
in terms of resources say
you have a company theme
or our markdown template that you want
to
share
and so rather than having that kind of
siloed and different
file structures and things like that
having it in an easily findable spot on
your blog
um
can make it a lot easier for folks to
you know find them use these themes etc
and similarly if there are different
kinds of uh talks or sorts of content
then it makes sense to
uh to keep saved within your team for
this institutional knowledge that you
have the option for that as well and so
i just wanted to show a quick example of
what this could look like um
particularly if if you are interested in
cultivating a
data science community with your team
members
and so now i am going to
move to an example of how to set up hugo
apparel and blog down
and so this is on github
and go into my repositories i'm going to
start uh in a project from scratch
however i guess it's not fully from
scratch i would say that there are a few
things that you will need to have
already set up you will need our norse
well if you use the rcu id like i do and
you need to have that set up and your r
studio needs to be connected with your
github page as well
and so
uh if those are in place then you can
create a new
repository for your website
and so let's call it new
log down blog
we're going to initialize this with a
readme file
did i not initialize it
and then moving to our studio we're
going to file
new project
version control
and get
and open this up
and so now we have a repository in our
studio ide that it's linked to our
github page and this is where the folder
in um our project in which we're going
to create our blog down website
and so if you go to file
uh
i actually put this in the repository
that i mentioned earlier the snippet for
actually creating a new website
[Music]
so down here under block down resources
getting started uh
we are also assuming that you have blog
down installed as well as hubo uh and if
you don't when you start the process uh
then it will prompt you to install the
things that you need
in addition that website that i just
mentioned uh the hugo apparel website
which is right here has amazing
very detailed instructions on how to get
set up
using lockdown hugo and hugo apparel
specifically
so i already have
log down installed so i can
call in my library
and then create a new site
using the hebrew apparel theme
now it's just downloading
okay so the new site is ready and it uh
actually asks me if i want to serve and
preview the site i'm going to say yes so
that we can take a look
this is a local version of our website
uh this is what we would be editing so
this is the blank template
from which you start your uh hugo
apparel
theme and as you can see like we
mentioned earlier has the blog option
the
projects and the talks etc
and so
i'm going to talk through a few of the
files that are important to know
so uh config.tomo
i think it's how you pronounce it uh is
your site configuration and so as you
can see here there's already inputs
available as the default but you would
change things like the title to the
title that you're interested in for your
particular website your your actual name
um etc
the
other thing i want to mention is hugo
apparel actually has a lot of built-in
themes and so if we go here it has this
sort of coloring
say that we want to use another sort of
color so forest some more green so we
would change it here
save
and if you can tell it actually changed
the color uh
by serving the site with once we saved
the file so if we open this up it looks
a little bit different it's uh green now
yeah change it one more time just
as an example so now we're going to
change it from forest to violet this is
safe
and now
it is this purplish color
another thing to mention is hugo apparel
also has built-in fonts so uh this kind
of script that you see here you can also
change uh with some of the predefined
fonts that that are already in place so
say we want to change commissioner to
metropolis
it's going to
move that out and you can see that the
font has changed as well
um but like mentioned earlier like the
the websites built with
are actually very customizable and so
you can actually you know change the css
to be very specific if it's for an
internal data science team and you want
it to reflect your company's fonts and
colors and you can do that as well and
so there are
lots of different configurations that
you can try depending on what you are
interested in
and just to showcase what it looks like
to
change some information so this is the
front page
and so
within these folders are
i find it very useful that there are
like already um
text and everything available because
it's very easy to see you know if you
make a change what exactly happens and
uh it will also very much let you know
if you made an error
as the site won't render um
and so as you can see here the text here
says sit down relax and get something
keep apparel and that is actually um
configured through this file called
underscore index.md in the content
folder
and so
if we were to change that you as you can
imagine it would also change the front
page of the website
as well
so i'm gonna write welcome
as you can see here though that block of
text went away it now just says welcome
um
like like we asked it to
and
just another thing to notice uh this
blog has this particular look but this
can also be configured as well with the
pre-defined
section options that
that hugo apparel has and so if we go to
content and blog this is a particular
blog and again
index.nd
and scroll
down
so it says here a sidebar for your
thoughts
and
that's the title here
you could change it to sidebar for your
thoughts too
and then you can see it has changed here
in addition uh the hugo apparel
documentation is also showcase the
different kinds of looks that you can go
through
if you want to
really really change it up from the
default
so i'm going to commit all of these
changes let's say like your your site is
ready to go you want it to
um you want to deploy it and have it
shareable with others because right now
it's just sitting in your computer you
can say kind of a website
great message but it works and then push
up to your repository
so now we can see all the files have
been included into our repository
and so
uh one option for deploying your website
is
called netlify and it's actually what i
use for my personal website as you can
see here
and it makes it very easy by integrating
with github if you have used github and
for a paid plan you can actually um
password protected or or keep it a
private if it is something that you are
considering for
um
for your team
and so
if we go here just to show what it looks
like to
import it
a new project
we connect with github
i'm already authorized
and i call it
just making sure i called it
so you can see i was testing things out
earlier
yes when you log down blog
you can click it
deploy sites
and site deploy in progress and this
should just take a couple of minutes but
then you will be able to share your
website uh using a url similar to
um this one that i showed you earlier is
also deployed on netlify
and you can change that url you can add
a custom one and there's rbind.io which
a lot of folks use for their personal
websites and that is one
option for you
and so now i'm going to go through the
second tool that i mentioned which is
called distill so i'm going to close
this project
so if you recall for hugo apparel we
created a new github repository we
cloned that repository into our studio
and then we used that script to create
our blog
both the still and blog down actually
have an add-in that you can use instead
within the rstudio ide so i'm going to
show what that looks like now uh so that
means that this one won't be connected
to
github but and you have seen what the
process looks like in that case so file
new project
and this is also assuming that you have
the still already installed
let's say that so
directory
and down here you can see there's
website using blog down
and then there's also the still blog so
we're going to click that and then you
install vlog
and you can change the title for it as
well
so create project i'm gonna go ahead and
do that
and so i have to admit i had not used
this bill until preparing for this part
for this presentation
so it's very much new to me but
uh just to showcase a few examples of
what it looks like
this is the distilled blog which is
created using the still and you can kind
of see what uh the the look
um
you know the general look
and
it's very clean very very fresh and very
much well suited for scientific
writing and so if you go to
the actual
it's the website
you can see some of these uh different
uh
options that you have for your
scientific writing if you so choose so
for example
if you have a lot of footnotes uh this
will show up if and once you like hover
over you're able to see you know the
text
and things like citations are very
readily available on distill so it's a
great platform for this particular kind
of writing and uh for folks who just
like you know the look and feel of this
particular blog
and another resource that i have
included in the resources is called the
distillery and this gives you a lot more
options in terms of
customizing your distilled site if you
so choose
so going back to our rstudio we have our
our distilled side uh ready to go
you can actually see it if you go into
this underscore site
index.html
and this is what the default looks like
so you can see your blog you can see
your blog post etc
uh
slightly different than blog down is if
you want to create a post you do create
a post
and we're going to do a new post
and so you can see here the sorts of
configuration that you have for your
post in terms of author etc and you can
write in our markdown script um like you
normally would and if you want to see
what it would actually look like on your
website you would click knit
so now you can see what your new post
looks like if you go back to your front
page you can see like like a blog it's
listed in order and um
and
it's
very straightforward in terms of
creating a new post and having it show
up
on your website
i'm going to show a slightly different
way of publishing your website
specifically if you're interested in
keeping your website behind your
firewall
uh our studio connect is an enterprise
product from our studio it allows for
publishing of things like shiny apps uh
dash apps and many many different things
including our markdown files and
actually
uh websites created with our markdown as
well
and so
i am going to show an example
of what it looks like to publish a
website
i actually have two accounts on our
studio are on connect and so i need to
specify which one i
and so by typing this
it deploys the website to our studio
connect
it is deploying the website
and now it's deployed successfully this
is what i meant to show you in the
beginning and so this is our studio
connect like i mentioned an enterprise
product from our studio and so
with it you can also host these websites
and if uh your company has our studio
connect the nice thing about this is
it's behind the firewall and so you can
specify specific folks to
access your website you can make it so
that anybody on your rstudio connect
account can access the website or you
can open it up to absolutely anybody uh
so i just wanted to really like quickly
showcase this and what it looks like
say to have like a website behind a
firewall
on our studio connect
and so with that um that is all i have
for today again uh please consider this
an open call for
if you have a story about data science
please contribute or consider
contributing to the data science
or the rco blog
we have examples like if you've built an
awesome package that you want to share
with others
um
a
uh also
a post on like a particular tool that
you've used and how you used it and
inspired others in data science so
this is
one we're showcasing our ceo cloud for
teaching others data science
and then also if you just want to share
your story and work together with me i'm
happy to work with you together on a
blog post and i would just love to hear
from you
and so with that i think it is time for
questions thank you so so much
thank you so much isabella
i see a lot of people asking for the
links to your github too to use some of
those examples so thank you for for
putting that all there
um i can start reading some of the
questions from slido but feel free to
raise your hand
to
unzoom if you want to ask anything live
as well
so let me move over to
slido
and one of the questions was when
deciding between using a hugo framework
or distill
are we fixed with that choice or is it
easy to switch between both if you
change your mind
yeah i'd say as somebody who has
switched their personal blog thing a few
times there are definitely some uh some
details that you need to
take into account for example different
themes might have a different setup for
like the top part of the post
and so
it won't necessarily just work to say
copy and paste all of your files over so
i would say no you're not stuck with a
particular theme but you have to be
aware of how you'd have to change things
up if you want to yeah you know move to
something new
thank you
um
send me an apologies if i'm pronouncing
your name incorrectly i see you have
your hand raised if you'd like to ask
that live
yes uh thank you very much uh isabella
for a wonderful presentation on using
blog dumb package
but like for me the concern is like is
there any way in which uh looking at the
hugo appero team
you know we have a contact page
is there any way we can link that
contact page directly to our email
without me using uh the form spray
package is a way i can go about that
thank you
yeah
i am actually not a hundred percent sure
uh having only used forms free before
but uh there is also of course like
different options for contact forms um
or you know linking
and
if you want to share your email or
things like that but i would have to do
a little bit of research and get back to
you for more information
thanks isabella
um and then just a quick note for some
of the questions in the chat if you just
if you want to make sure that we don't
miss them i'll put the slido link in
there again as well just sometimes they
get caught in between comments and i
don't want to miss any of them
but arun i see you had a question
do we want to know html css yaml or
those kind of things to get started with
blog down
and feel free to jump in everyone if you
want to add any other context
i think the question is just do you need
to know html and css
to get started
i would say no to get started uh i think
the package has a lot of
information and configuration to help
you get started if you noticed um if we
wanted to edit a particular post we just
had to go in and
change the text up
i would say like knowing r and r
markdown is more of a requirement if
you're specifically hoping to to
write a blog on
using our markdown
and but of course html and css will help
you configure your site a little bit
more and i would also say that the
artwork down team has done amazing work
in creating different sorts of
packages that help you create more
configuration for your arm markdown
your shiny apps and things like that
without needing to know you know
everything there is to know about css um
actually there is an r enterprise uh
meetup that uh on business reports using
our markdown that was incredibly uh
helpful and kind of showcasing the
different
avenues for use for configuring you know
these different types of content without
like having to know a ton of css
i just put the youtube link to that one
too if anyone wants to to save it sorry
it starts playing an ad the second you
click on it
um
there was another question i see millie
you had a question around how do you
change the url
um and i know there was a lot of great
conversation happening in the chat as
well
millie would you want to jump in and
provide any context on that question
um yeah i think alex helped answer that
because i'm using um block down the hugo
power theme and i'm still like working
on my local computer but i was wondering
how you end up changing the url
um so that
yeah it like reflects what you wanted to
be instead of the um strange i guess
animal or whatever character that they
give you
yeah some of the names are very
interesting
um
yeah i'm glad the question was answered
and uh be sure to look at the chat later
um at least like for my personal website
i use the arbonne.io
um option that i mentioned earlier uh i
can
find that how to do that it's actually
in the blog down book as well um
and then if you want a custom url
uh we've used uh
the ones that are using a
uh cheap cheap name i think it's called
uh to um
to use a custom url but we did have to
pay in that particular case this was for
art lady seattle
thank you
i know um
millie you had another question earlier
too i just wanted to make sure we didn't
miss but
that was isabel do you have any tips for
content writing do you have the most
impact for the audience
i think
um
for sure
there are
some sorts of
kind of guidelines like you want to make
sure that your title is catchy that it
conveys like what you are going to
display within um the actual post itself
and there are like uh
some things that are like kind of known
in that particular case like folks
really like lists or how to's uh and you
can kind of like uh create your your
work around that but i do think it
really like
it depends on what you are interested
and what your goals are like i mentioned
earlier um that
if
if
like somebody is searching for something
like what do you want them to put into
you know their their search bar and be
able to find like your post and consider
it that way
so that's uh for
like the title in terms of like the
content within the post
there are also some sort of some
guidelines that folks say like you don't
want a blog post that's too long but you
don't want one that's too short and
things like that but i think it's more
about um
displaying like the
the
what you what you really want and
sometimes you know if considering like
oh maybe this could be a series of posts
as opposed to one particular pose um can
you make it more engaging if it's for a
personal post maybe like adding memes or
you know funny images or things like
that uh if it's more
serious making sure that your headers
are very clear
that somebody you know quickly going
through the blog post can easily find
the section that they're interested in
and things like that
thanks isabella i i see larry you had
your hand raised earlier would you want
to ask your question live
is there a way to connect google
analytics to this coding
to keep track of site visits or anything
like that
yes if you go to the con the
configuration file that i showed you
earlier there's actually a space there
for google analytics and so once you
have configured your google analytics
dashboard you put the
um
the the code or the id that they give
you in there and then it'll
automatically start feeding
google analytics information for your
site
oh thank you so much
i see juan you had a question earlier if
you're still on around the our markdown
slides
or if they were done with our markdown
do you want to ask your question live
the the question was isabella were your
slides done with our markdown juan
really liked them and wanted to know how
you made them and if there was a
tutorial
also for some of the animations
for sure uh it actually was not our
markdown it's called quarto
and so created by the our studio team
and i'll put the link there
and it creates presentations using
reveal.js and uh and it's actually
integrated with our markdown and so
because they can speak to each other and
so um it yeah so that's what i
i created the slides with
cool i love those too
i am i'm checking slido i don't see any
of the other questions there but let me
go through the chat here and again feel
free to raise your hand or even just
unmute yourself and jump in with other
questions too
um shameless just asked what makes porto
different from our markdown
yeah quarto is built on pandoc and it
like our markdown can work on a variety
of different um
with a variety of different languages
and in a variety of different uh
editors our studio vs code etc um yeah i
highly encourage looking at the website
and checking it out
and
thank you
um eugene i see
um had asked earlier how configurable is
the site without learning go
well well i would say i don't know any
go
so
um i think that it's quite configurable
and so for example the hugo apparel
theme that i mentioned earlier uh
it
to edit say like the colors um you can
use the pre-configured settings that
they already have you want to configure
the fonts you can work in css or
something called
sass and um
you know it makes it very
straightforward
in terms of like not having to know any
go to to make your site look the way
that you want it to
thank you so much isabella
i was just curious if other people on
the call have
built their own blogs if you wanted to
share them in the chat
or also if anybody had built an internal
blog for like their own company meetup
um i would love to hear more about
examples of that too
awesome
thank you for sharing your blog there
taiwan
rolling through to see if there are any
other questions too
um adnan i see you just asked a question
about
the ideal length um do you want to jump
in and ask that
also don't feel like anybody has to
to jump in just trying to uh make us
feel like we're in person
but um the question was what would be
the ideal length in terms of word count
for a blog post let's say for an eda
post where we present our analysis
yeah
so i think again there are sorts of
guidelines out there um i feel like for
an ideal blog post please let's say like
uh 1 000 words or something like that um
but i would say to the
uh blog like many other things are a
great opportunity to try out sort of
data analysis and data science skills so
if you have the ability to a b test you
know trying out different things with
different
groups of folks and seeing what seems to
resonate the most i would also say like
it very much depends too on the the
content that you're sharing like some
things might just need a
um shorter version of of a blog post
versus some that go more in depth and so
there's also so many different things
that you can tweak uh what day do you
post what time do you post and things
like that and i think it's trying to
understand your audience take a look at
past data trying things out and seeing
how
what what ends up happening in order to
really develop your blog strategy
i see a few people had asked about where
to find the recording um and so i do put
them up to the rstudio youtube we have a
playlist called enterprise community
meetups
it takes a few days just to like edit it
and work with our team to upload it so
i'll also just put the zoom recording
um in the meetup
like details like for the actual event
um right after this i can put that there
it just won't be the edited version
um
but also just was thinking i may as well
put in a little plug and let people know
that
on thursday we also have another
meet up um on putting shiny into
production
and so that's a meet up with the dutch
national institute for public health
and you actually saw a little sneak
preview of their app in the blog post
that isabella shared
so i will
copy the link to that if you want to
just add it to your calendar
are there any other questions or
anything that i missed
oh tony i see you asked a question
around blog frequency
is once a month a good frequency for
blog posts
yes
i'd say um i it can it
depends
uh if and referring to your personal
blog
at least like
for myself i
try to aim for once a quarter actually
um but i think you know that's that's
for
my own personal uh writing goals and for
a company blog it might be a little
different you might want to be more
continuously putting out content um
for example we we aim for twice a week
um and so i think it's again based on
your goals uh what direction you want
the blog to go to
um
yeah like ultimately what are you
looking for are you looking for research
ability within google are you looking
for something else and uh also what's
feasible for for you and your team as
well
thank you isabella and i know you
mentioned at the end as well that if
people have ideas for blog posts or
maybe like new packages that they've
created and want to share that on the r
studio blog that they can reach out to
you
is it best through linkedin or twitter
or how should people connect yeah i
would love to connect with you even if
it's not for a blog post would just love
um to chat and say hello uh but yes if
you are interested particularly in a
blog post i have my email on the slides
feel free to reach out that way but um
linkedin twitter on i check everything
all the time so would just love to hear
from you
perfect
yeah if anyone ever has questions about
anything maybe mentioned in the meetups
or about our studio tools or anything
like that you can always reach out to me
too and
i'll just put my email
in the chat window
too um and the last thing i forgot to
also share was
if you'd ever like to speak at a meet up
too or if you have
maybe an indus a certain industry
presentation or you want to help get the
community together i would love to help
foster that um
and then
if you have other feedback for
things you'd just like to see i'll put a
few forms into the chat window right now
too
isabella do you see any questions that
we missed
[Music]
so but i'm very excited to look through
everybody's website i really appreciate
it
yeah it's so fun to see everybody's
blogs shared there too i know
a great place that i've been able to
find some blog posts is through our
weekly
but curious how
you stay up to date on another blogs too
isabella
yeah our weekly definitely our bloggers
another place that i really like to book
um
and uh yeah the maintainer actually
created a website for python bloggers
which is also very useful
and um
just generally like social media
whenever folks post things on linkedin
or on twitter i think like that's a huge
help in terms of finding you know
different resources and various
community groups also help kind of
aggregate different things so
for example our ladies has started
compiling all the different our ladies
websites so and it's just generally
useful to keep that bookmarked and check
it out whenever there are updates
awesome and so that example that you
created and like the fake internal
meetup group can people so people can
just take that and apply it
to their own company if they wanted to
like use it as a starting point
yeah absolutely uh that's also on my
repository i can actually
share the link right now
um
so
like we walk through today can either
start a new project with hugo apparel or
if you feel comfortable you know taking
this
creating a clone and editing it to what
you need that's another option as well
perfect
well there are no other questions
thank you so much isabella for this walk
through and and all the resources this
was awesome i love this
so thanks thanks rachel for the
opportunity and thank you all so much
for for joining